it's great to welcome back to the
program today Frank mink who is a former
neo-nazi who we actually met every time
I feel like it's important to tell the
story Frank we met because you and I
years ago we're scheduled to be on dr.
Drew's CNN Headline News Show on the
same day they introduced we are going to
talk now to former neo-nazi Frank mink
and they put up a picture of me as a
very clean-cut maybe the most clean-cut
former neo-nazi ever and then we figured
out oh okay they actually put up the
wrong picture but that's how we got in
touch right and then you first made some
derogatory statements about how that you
would never held it people pointed out
that my look was a little bit too
chipper and clean-cut but I think that
that was other people not me who were
saying that so listen Frank I mean I
don't even know where to start at this
point but I guess what one place would
be in light of the recent shootings that
we've been seeing and the increased
radicalization that's that's heavily
anti-immigrant you and I have talked
about the anti-semitic radicalization
that you experienced when you were a
neo-nazi but we haven't talked so much
about the anti-immigrant stuff was that
a big part of your radicalization yes I
mean that's that's fear is one of the
main points of fear is that there going
to be people here now who are gonna come
and take our jobs I mean that was it's a
huge part of the building of the fear oh
they were losing our country because of
this and what I mean by we I mean white
people were losing our country so that
was the entire great was the
anti-immigration and is a huge part of
the movement itself and so now we're
seeing this like division between
there's the good immigrants and then the
not-so-good immigrants so we heard about
like s whole countries we heard about
like we want people from Norway but not
from Haiti or whatever when you were in
was the talk specifically about
immigrants from certain places
absolutely it was about African
immigrants that were coming over and so
you know the South American immigrants
we're coming up to you know to destroy
our country and when you now see like
the manifesto that was left in the El
Paso shooting and you see some of that
phraseology like this is the language
ring a bell to you it's it's exactly the
same Burbage it's exactly the same
rhetoric were for were stuff that we
said in the nineties exam we talked
about this before how the alright is
just rebranding itself but it has to be
brain itself because it can't say it's
just like we were in the nineties so and
that's why it's like the right now
they're kind of classy it up a little
bit but they're still the same rhetoric
the same hatred the same fear is all
there I mean just think that there's
people that are down in Phoenix who go
out and they get using militias now and
they go out and they shoot up all the
water tanks now that people we were the
immigrants who are coming over again
illegally but they're still human beings
and these guys are shooting up water
tanks that these churches are leading
out for them exciting don't die of
thirst and so like there's ways that
these guys are really starting to gather
momentum and I think they're also you
know and this is not I can't say for a
fact but I'm feeling that there's you
know some killings have been going on
because it's the desert you know it's a
big desert out there so they go around
they look for illegal immigrants coming
and they're their own little militias
and so I know they shoot up the water
tanks that's definite and so I wonder
what else they shoot off let me find an
immigrant coming across the border
one of the things that I've been talking
about is that there's sort of like a
line or kind of like a threshold where
someone can have a lot of these
anti-immigrant and radicalized ideas
that you had but not act on them in
terms of physical violence like they can
believe this stuff but they don't
actually translate it into real-world
violence and then something happens and
some people go beyond and now they're
doing real-world violence can you talk
about from when you were in what was it
that seemed to separate the people who
just had the ideology from the ones who
were willing to go and do the real world
violence yes we did
the guys who do the violence are it goes
from the top down it's the guys that are
higher up are usually the more violent
ones so and then the more that you get
down to the less guys that are just
doing then you start to find you know
the more the guys who still have a
little bit of compassion left in
themselves and a little bit of empathy
left so it's the higher-ups who are
doing the more of the violence it's not
like they're sending out hits him in now
that it's so the militia guys are the
guys are doing all this violence that's
kind of entering in question in a way
that's interesting so now with the
internet the radicalization is not
happening as much in a social group I
mean you talked about based on your
childhood and everything that was going
on in your life how there was like a
significant social element to your
radicalization
now with the internet a lot of these
individuals are being radicalized by
websites and rhetoric from people that
they'd ever meet personally does that
make it more dangerous in a way or is it
just different or how should we think
about that no it's a lot more dangerous
it's really more dangerous and there are
absolutely there's a lone wolf you have
people that want to be Timothy McVeigh
who they idolize Timothy McVeigh they
idolize these shooters you go on all
their websites right now it's you know
in their chat rooms they're idolizing
these people and that's building more
people that want to be like me that I
wanted to be idolized I mean I had
nothing in life I mean I had and when
someone said that God wanted me to do
these bad things to people it was you
know the way of me having a purpose in
life I don't want to say idolize but you
know you want to have a purpose and now
these guys have a purpose but just going
out and shooting shooting up a school or
shooting up a synagogue or shooting up
something that's you know they are all
getting memorialized now because of its
no and it all goes back to the lone wolf
but Timothy McVeigh where and that's the
thing that got me out well I was already
out but that was the thing that made me
think I need to rethink what I'm doing
because of the Timothy McVeigh's type
stuff did then fire and the final did
that little girl on his arm is the
picture that will forever last in my my
brain
my rhetoric help preach my brighter that
I preach help you know help him form his
beliefs to do that not per se me but I
was definitely a leading person in the
movement at the time when he was getting
this seems super important to me that
this lone wolf thing you're talking
about because in the last five years
it's become super popular for people who
don't want to accept that there is this
radicalization going on to say it was
only a lone wolf we don't have to worry
as much because it's not part of some
organized group you're pointing out
something really important which is this
is just a result of the fact that the
Internet has become as ubiquitous as it
is it's going to be a lot of lone wolves
because you no longer need to do what
Frank mink did which was you were part
of like a physical social group that
doesn't make it less dangerous if
anything we should be more worried about
how easily these lone wolves are being
radicalized Jesus I mean no it's it's
scary and the fact that it just goes one
person who can just have an incident
with something at school I mean that's
where I've been getting a lot of calls
work kids get into it just because
they're having trouble at school like I
did with the black kids at school and
then next thing you know now he's going
on these websites and inventing and
finding other people who matched what
he's saying and again we're dealing with
people that are full of fear or
egomaniacs with no self-esteem I mean
that's what you're dealing with that's
what you deal with with radicalized kids
all across the world we now have had
organizations where we meet and talk to
other formers former jihadis former bars
I mean you name it we have former IRA
bombers we all got the other an eye on
the net and tried to figure out what's
going on and it's all the same they're
the same makeup as I was a kid who had
nothing in life and now someone says
that God wants me to be this this person
God wants me to be on his team which he
wanted me to ruin Sodom and Gomorrah so
you know net
that would have been a lot more easier
for me to be radicalized I would have
been who knows where I would have been
if there would have been the internet
when I was younger so when you talk to
the other formers from different
extremist groups is there any common
thread that links what got them out like
you talked about around the Timothy
McVeigh time you were already starting
to be pulled out of it has there been
anything that you've determined that
seems to have been a common factor in
all of these different extremists that
left their respective movements yeah
empathy finding empathy again from other
people from other people from and that's
what I always say I never marched in the
Klan rallies when I marked with the Klan
and March with the neo-nazis and people
threw bottles at us I never ducked a
bottle but oh I better I better rethink
my beliefs here I never ducked the
bottom I thought that I thought my enemy
so what is when people started to talk
to me and be real with me and started to
have conversations that were heartfelt
and real and later on would make me
question my beliefs you know like there
is a bunch of people like Keith Brooke
Stein who was the Jewish antique dealer
who I don't really cement my final
change was one of those guys who just he
didn't care what I believe he just cared
I didn't break his furniture because I
worked for this furniture store and you
know but it was just a good man and he
he talked him he talked me like a human
being something that no one had done
everyone else want to argue with me all
the time about my beliefs that's all
everyone wanted to do is leave that
stupid stuff I've heard that my whole
life you know when someone has started
talking me about me just being me and
being standing by myself and being human
being and not being stupid like I
thought I was my parents adore me I was
you know I came up pretty hard so it was
that type of new human interaction that
made me perked the question and that's
the same thing across the board with
everyone is they had some type of
interaction where so many people met the
people that they did terrorist attacks
to they met the people and then were
forgiven and I was a huge thing is
because what we need to do is we need to
forgive when these guys get out of
neo-nazi world
I know people hate to hear this but we
have to forgive them we can't say we
don't want them around
anymore but when they try to get out of
it and he's young them more I believe
that stuff comes down to this idea of
like being irredeemable at a certain
point right that people get to a certain
point and then society decides doesn't
matter what you do from this point
forward everything you've done up until
now makes you irritable which is one of
the problems arguably with like the
criminal justice system that we have in
the country but you're saying that if
people become irredeemable then they're
almost like lost forever in some sense
because what they need is that
redemption in some way absolutely they
need to be the good guy they need to be
on the right team and so what I always
thought I thought that I was on the good
even when I was near not to have thought
I was for the white race and that
everything was coming to destroy but
once I started to realize that way what
I was believing was a bait and switch i
was baiting switched to believe that i
was proud of a heritage but we never
talked about our heritage we always
talked about everyone else's Harwich
like I was baiting switched into this
this movement so that when I started to
realize that I was not looked at as
being dumb or stupid or whatever for
believing this stuff but people just
said I understand why I believe that I
did it I understand that and that came
from people of all races who came to me
and said it and same thing with the
people that are also farmers now this I
don't know if you heard on my CNN
interview where I talked about the
Donald Trump in taking money away from
life after hate which is an organization
I helped found it yeah great
organization and he took that money away
$400,000 he took it away because we
wanted more money to go towards Muslim
extremists well look where that's gotten
us now like now we have we're starting
in the hole to get back now the catch
back up to this because they've been so
worried about Muslim extremists which
haven't killed nowhere near as much
people as the right wing and the right
the right has so so let's talk a little
bit about Trump so last time you were on
I mean it's crazy because when I had
Richard Spencer on the white nationalist
and when I had you on you both had
similar views about the signals that
Trump sends and both of you to summarize
very crudely said he's not using all of
the language that a real white
nationalist would necessarily be using
but if you know the talking
points you see the signals and that's
enough to get people coalesced around
him do you still feel that way the term
invasion infestation all of that stuff
oh it looks like we lost Frank here
Frank can you uh Frank put us on whole
you put us on hold there Frank oh now
you're back okay we lost you at a key
moment there and yes so sorry no problem
you try and get this thing right now
yeah so anyway I wouldn't get back to
this point because this is yeah yeah the
signals that are sent by the language
that's being used so so what I have to
do it what I think of him what I think
of his responses for the shooting it was
he was very scripted in his response
that white supremacist needs to be you
know disavowed or something he said it's
just discussing the whole truth what he
what he really believes in earth what
I've seen from his tweets that he's
tweeted about Baltimore and about other
people that are people of color and make
them go back to their own country like
that's the same stuff that we used to
say go back to your own country even
though black people been here longer
than mostly all white people's heritage
have because their heritage was here
slavery obviously so there are heritage
is here a lot longer than us so how we
should they should be telling us to go
back to our country but well you know
let's never mind that part or let's go
with um you know the wife his wife used
you know yes I think she might be a
Russian spy I swear to you but but so
what you're saying is super important
which is and by the way Frank your
cameras just bouncing all over the place
there if there's anything you can do
about it to study it that would be
awesome it's just bouncing up and down
one of the things we're pointing out is
if you've been paying attention to
everything that Trump has been saying
for years and then this one time he says
we should disavow white supremacy it
doesn't totally hold true in in a sense
you're still going by all the things
he's been saying for the last two and a
half years that's right absolutely and
and it's a fact
that he is sorry about that my cameras
down so it's a fact that he says things
that are exactly what we were saying
back then it's a it's a true fact it's
not he uses the same type of rhetoric
same type of fear basing fear tactics
that Fox News uses all the time
Fox News is legendary in that they
always are fear-based stuff Fox and
Friends in the morning is not very
friendly it's not very fun not buoyant
at all it's it's very much they're
coming for us
they're coming in droves from there what
did the convoy he was coming up here
with all those people so it's just it's
really bad it's it's really I'm really
worried about where we're headed now as
a country and I think the last time I
might've been on I might have been more
optimistic because I thought that maybe
Donald Trump would be more of a man and
say you know that this stuff is wrong
and stop trying to stick to a base of
people that are just blindly following
him so well one of the things you said
before we started today's interview is
that you now are talking to your kids
about not fire or smoke at school and
how to get out
but these shooter scenarios what is it
like I mean to some degree
these are you're talking to your kids
about how to protect themselves from
shooters that have potentially been
radicalized by the ideology that once
held you so closely a radicalized what
is that like oh sorry sorry trying to
just be good okay so okay all right so
what I have to say about that is my kids
told me yesterday we were talking about
this and they said that they do these
shooting things were a school where they
have to go there's a shooter in her
school and stay in their class and I'm
gonna lock them doors and all this stuff
so we used to prepare for Russians to
come in and pack ice needs to prepare
like when I was a little kid I remember
we used to go and hide under our desk in
case there's a nuclear bomb like that
was really gonna save us but whatever
yeah then we were prepared for Americans
coming in and killing our own people in
our schools like
what we're preparing our kids for and
it's all due to you know gun violence
and mental health you know mental
illness and stuff that you talk about
all the time how we could talk about
mental illness but we're cutting funding
to real mental illness issues and the
places that are for mental health
they're cutting it funding and they're
saying that we don't want to pay for
insurance for that stuff but also now we
want to make sure they're bad guys so
it's it's just weird that my kids are
planning on another American coming in
and killing them
like that's what they're you know they
talked about it yesterday about it
though what they've been doing at school
about their drills and stuff so nine
total is to keep running they're coming
years will just keep running no matter
but just keep running don't stay still
and so it was just really real
conversation you have with kids nowadays
about other Americans coming in knowing
them not in her rank knowing how you
became radicalized what do you do with
your kids to prevent them from being
sucked in by any of these movements
teaching them teaching them empathy
teaching oh man with you from they want
in fact I mean me my daughter still only
walk we always pick up trash in a way
just to give you an example every day
when we walk to the store we always pick
up a piece of trash even if it's not on
my property it's not someone else we
just do it because it makes our
community a better place and you just no
matter if you see someone throws
something is you'll pick it up and just
by teaching them the small basic things
of respect for other people's property
or other people's just this whole
community in one the community and so my
kids like the n-word is not acceptable
in our home at all like not acceptable
at all like as white people I think
we've abused that word we should never
be able to use they again I think it
might be a recreation thing but anyway
my work that word is not able to be used
in our home and also our friends of we
have friends of all I mean we are my
daughter's best friend is is the best
friend is a black kid who's this you
know he's just the light of our life
they mean he comes over and he
just you know that's her best friend and
that's I hopefully due to the way that
we have raised her to accept everyone's
as who they are
Frank mink always a pleasure talking to
you Frank really appreciate it
appreciate your insights and look
forward to having you back on again
about the camera I'll give you camera
next time sorry thanks Frank